uh i am not being hyperbolic here i am
going to show you clips of what i
believe is donald trump's worst
interview uh that i've ever seen him
give and i i'm not going to say it's
significantly worse than the jonathan
swan axios interview it may be equally
bad
but this is at least equally bad in
terms of being trump's worst interview
that i have ever seen
uh
i read that this took place and i
couldn't believe it i had to go and find
the clip for myself i read that sean
hannity asked trump about biden's
strategy of metaphorically banging your
head against the wall and expecting
results from that it was a metaphor the
metaphor of banging your head against
the wall
donald trump answered that the wall
would have been done in three weeks if
he had been reelected
please understand what i'm saying
hannity talks about metaphorically
banging your head against the wall
and trump answers about the literal wall
that he claims he was building on the
u.s mexico border
and people are questioning joe biden's
cognitive state listen to this
so you know it's you know you keep
banging your head against the wall
why would you expect a different result
so we would have had the wall completed
in three weeks it was largely completed
so
guys it's this is a former president
it's a former president
um at another point during the interview
hannity says trump created monoclonal
antibodies now i've heard trump be
wrongly credited with creating the
vaccines which he didn't do
hannity is saying trump created the
monoclonal antibodies as well i thought
it was regeneron take a listen
you left office with three vaccines and
monoclonal antibodies that you had
created which to this day i think is the
the best therapeutic i advise people to
talk to it's a therapruric um
what trump now created the antibodies
too like what what what is happening
people watch this people wan
just on the basis of those two clips
alone
this is the most insane interview i've
seen trump do
right up there with the jonathan swan
interview but then
you if i told you this you'd say david
sir it's 2022 this can't be going on
trump is still bragging about the
dementia test he's still talking about
it
do you believe he's struggling
cognitively because that question was
raised about you and i've been around
you long enough to know that that that's
not a problem for you at all
well i went and took a test and as uh
dr ronnie jackson who's great great guy
now he's a congressman and they love him
in texas but he said he aced it and i
don't think he ever saw anyone ace it
and i immediately said because they
started passing the false narrative
guys he's still bragging about the
dimensions as he thinks it's an iq test
he thinks that doing well on a test
meant to screen out
relatively serious dementia that he's
worthy of mensa membership or so i mean
it
it's 2022 and he's still doing it
in a moment totally beyond parody in
criticizing joe biden's thus far
handling of the ukraine russia situation
trump says he never had a problem with
ukraine
what about the impeachment related to
ukraine what what these things would
have happened you wouldn't have had
inflation you wouldn't have had ukraine
problems with russia it was all working
out everything was fine the guy was
impeached over his problems with ukraine
continuing now
that i've i've never seen an interview
like that it's every answer is from
another planet
trump says windmills
are ruining
the atmosphere guys wind farms wind
power and if you could start that up
again
and stop with all of the windmills all
over the place that are ruining the
atmosphere you look at what's happening
to these beautiful prairies and plains
and these gorgeous areas of our country
where they have these rusting hulks put
up all over the place where that are
noisy they're killing the birds i mean i
i don't get the environmental scent it's
a very expensive form probably the most
expensive form of energy now understand
there's we could just do an hour on wind
energy understand that each of these
things has been studied first and
foremost when technologies are newer
they are nowhere near full efficiency so
without a doubt wind power will become
more efficient meaning being able to
harvest more power generate more power
from the same amount of wind that's
that's we've seen it with solar panels
we've seen it all over the place the
bird stuff has been studied extensively
and while um it is true that some birds
are killed due to wind farms
the number of animals killed by fossil
fuels is orders of magnitude greater on
a per-energy basis it's been studied but
this is the stuff that the fox audience
accepts uncritically now last clip here
and this is again i i can't believe we
are it's we if there's ever been
evidence that we're in a simulation it's
that trump's still doing this stuff
trump again brags about the size of the
crowd at the insurrection
and with a lot less than twenty thousand
troops also the fact is i knew it was
going to be a massive rally because this
was a protest rally against the election
which they considered to be totally
rigged they were right and this was a
protest against the election and i was
told by so many people oh we're going
down on the six we're going down and i
that's why i met with
the top people the top people in
military and other places and i said
i think this is going to be a lot of
people coming down i can tell you i
spoke i believe it was the biggest crowd
i've ever spoken to it was massive
the absolute biggest crowd
ever incited by a president to attempt
an insurrection
we have never seen anything like this
truly and the majority of the republican
party based on all recent polling wants
four more years of that and they may get
it
they may get it depending on what
happens in 2022 and of course what
happens with trump's health and whether
joe biden runs again and all these
different things but
more than half of them want it and they
may get it which is absolutely
horrifying
if you're having trouble thinking of
what to give someone as a holiday gift
check out our sponsor shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering the ingredients and recipes
for craft cocktails right to your door
they send you everything you need to
make the cocktails except for the
alcohol you provide that it comes with a
really nice recipe card easy to follow
my most recent shaker and spoon cocktail
creation was called the capri crush it's
a camparian gin drink with spiced orange
grapefruit cordial and dashfire orange
bitters delicious my turned out great i
know nothing about mixing drinks neither
do most of my friends but with my shaker
and spoon cocktails i ended up looking
like i knew something about it which is
good it's very good for my cred
you don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get 20 off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout go to
com slash shakerandspoon.com
and the link is down below